[Music]
there's something special about the town
we call our hometown
for property manager and real estate
agent jamie rybin back that's
philadelphia pennsylvania hey jamie will
you show us around
hi drew my name is jamie viback and i'm
standing here in front of cbs3 in my
hometown of philadelphia i'm so excited
to show you around today i'm a real
estate agent here in philadelphia and
one of my favorite things to do is to
show people around who are coming to
philadelphia for the very first time
let's say hi to jim and janelle from the
cbs channel 3 morning show good morning
hi drew welcome to philly yes the city
of brotherly love and sister
thanks for joining us
welcome to the fabulous wedding terminal
market that's over 150 years old there's
more than 80 vendors everything from
buying gifts to pretzels to cookies to
ice cream i love coming here andrew i
cannot wait to show you what's inside
you're gonna love it you need to check
this place out best bagels best lofts
best cream cheese in the world love this
place rehearsals east side best
sandwiches anything is anybody in the
mood for cheese because if you are then
you've got to come to the real cheese
shop to find everything that you want
[Music]
when you come to philadelphia you have
to stop for a great cheesesteak so here
we are at chip steak on south street
let's try it out shall we
drew when you come here we're definitely
coming here for sure
here we are at the art museum the iconic
art museum at the end of our tour i hope
that you enjoyed yourself as much as i
did i love showing philly around
especially to viewers and i hope that
you enjoyed it as well drew i'm a huge
fan dating all the way back to e.t give
me a call when you come to town
thanks jamie i love phil leaf maybe we
can grab a cheesesteak sometimes maybe
from gino's
[Music]
you